President Trump says the investigation
into Russia's influence in the 2016
election is not interfering with his
agenda mr. Trump tweeted yesterday quote
they make America great again agenda is
doing very well
despite the distraction of the
witch-hunt Republican strategist and CBS
News contributor Frank Luntz spoke with
Trump supporters about what they think
of the president's performance the group
had 13 men and seven women ranging in
age from 20 to 63 all of them voted for
mr. Trump in November their opinions of
the president range from somewhat
unfavorable to extremely favorable did
the Russians intervene in this election
I mean they didn't get into the voting
machines and change votes it would have
made any difference one way or the other
now did they try to hack the election we
found out from the league or that woman
that yes they did but they weren't
successful should we be investigating
this yeah but not for the purpose I've
been investigated so you think we're
done there's nothing more to learn why
not learn more but don't do it for the
purpose of overturning an election do it
for the purpose of learning how we can
put walls up how we can keep isn't that
what's happening now
if the Russians affected the election
then that means they change the minds of
the American people and that's not what
happened the whole purpose of this is to
have an investigation to see if there
are specifics do you want to shut that
investigation down yeah why because it's
a giant huge waste of time if if there's
an investigation into this whole Russian
thing then it needs to be on well they
physically went into our machines hacked
our machines this whole hacking thing
and actually change the election results
people read fake stuff on Facebook
Twitter Instagram all day anybody can
put that up I can put it up you could
put it up okay so he's had we're now in
the middle of June I want you to give me
one word or phrase to describe Donald
Trump now that we have some idea of who
he is give me a word or phrase to
describe Donald Trump I'd say honest
and effective sure strong productive
tough sob very authentic how many of you
in this room loved the tweeting you
think it's really appropriate for a
president to do that it could be better
yeah yeah it could be better he needs to
tone down the language a little bit but
the bottom line is it's his way to get
the message out I would argue that
Donald Trump shouldn't tone it down this
brash brand that he has what got him
elected you know my thing is I'm so
tired of people beating on down the
Trump Donald Trump made his problem says
he kept them and that's the type of new
leadership that we need and what has he
accomplished what is he accomplished
he's done more in the last hundred days
than President Obama done in the last
eight years such as such as keeping his
promises I want to know what promises he
kept one thing one promise I can say
that he did keep is he elected a
conservative to the Supreme Court and
you know what that's the best promises
that promise that he's kept so far by
this point george w bush already had his
tax cut done good trick plus we don't
know much help from congress he is not
getting to Aqaba can caucus he talks
about draining the swamp and I think
what we're finding real quick in the
first hundred days is the swamp is not
just the Democrats there's more fighting
among the Republicans and there is
between the Republicans and Democrats on
his agenda and if they don't get it
figured out 2018 is gonna be ugly for
the Republicans who thinks he's gonna be
president for eight years raise your
hands let's say he doesn't get health
care let's say he doesn't get tax reform
let's say he doesn't get the investment
in infrastructure those are three key
commitments that he made who here would
consider not voting for him in that
situation raise your hands so you're
voting for him no matter what no matter
what no matter what he does I'm Donald
Trump what would you tell me stay
focused on the big picture issues and
get that legislative agenda passed
through on the economy and things will
get a lot better stay true to the
promises that you
um gave us listen to your cabinet and
Democrats aren't your enemies remember
what got you to the office remember the
people the promises were results orient
this critical stage of our country Frank
Luntz is here now Frank good to see you
thank you uh we talked about this during
the campaign what you're hearing now in
that piece is not that much different
than what we heard during the campaign
is not different at all it's just more
passionate and the divisions are just so
much deeper the Trump voters that what
surprised me the most about that segment
is when we showed Trump pushing aside
the European leaders at that meeting and
they applauded him they loved it because
to them it was the White House it was
the president asserting his rightful
role as leader the free world and I'm
thinking oh my god this is one of the
most embarrassing moments they don't see
it that way the push asides the
handshakes all of that they love it they
love it and they want him to keep doing
it are we talking about simply the hard
core and I mean that in the best sense
of the word people who voted to him or
are we talking just about them but also
those Democrats who came to vote for
Donald Trump and put him over the top
in 2016 his base is significant it is
small but significant and it isn't
weakening those who are in to the place
enough and is it all of what elected him
no it's not enough you cannot govern
successfully at 38 percent your goal is
to be at 50 point one this is the first
president I know in modern history that
accepts 40% as the center place that's a
challenge for him in getting tax reform
it's a challenge for health care it's a
challenge for infrastructure that said
the people who voted for him are still
behind him and you can see that
emotionally they are not behind the
Republican Party though there was sharp
criticism of what's happening in
Congress what are the implications for
2018 we're going to be showing this
tonight at nine o'clock and Paul Ryan
better tune in because it is the most
significant condemnation of the speaker
since what I heard Trump voters saying
about John Boehner about two years ago
they think Congress is holding up the
agenda they think Congress is part of
the swamp and they blame the Republicans
as well as the Democrats to where we're
going to show this at nine at nine
o'clock on CBS n now I feel like a
pitchman no I want I don't know what I
want to see it I'm p.m. one hour of this
frank luntz thanks as always great to
see you pleasure